[موسيقى]
الجانب الخاص بالعمل وكما ورد في الماده
الثانيه
و consider act to consider the act
alone as listed in article with no
reference at all to the intent criter is
to den the crime of very
essence the cour has stated that what is
required this stage is to establish the
act complain of are capable of falling
within
the
حقيقه وجود
ركن مرتبط بالماده الثانيه من الاتفاقيه
بمعنى
اخر هدله تبت وجاهه
هذه
جنوب افريقيا قبلت الحاجه الى اثبات ركن
النيه واشارت الى مفهوم وجود
نيه محدده في طلبها
وكذلك في مناقشه
موضوع الاختصاص الظاهري او المبدا للمحكمه
وجنوب افريقيا
وضعت اما كبيرا في حديث امس من قبل السيده
المحاميه حسيم السيد
اني كرس كل م رفعته لهذا الطلب او لهذا
الركن من الصعوبه اثبات ان اسرائيل كان
لديها النيه
لتدمير الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل كلي او جزئي
اننيه المرتبطه ب فضائع السابع من اكتوبر
وكذلك مواصله اطلاق صراح اطلاق صواريخ
وكذلك منع او عدم الافراج عن الرهائن جعل
اسرائيل تواصل عملياتها من اجل الدفاع عن
نفسها
وطلاق صراح المختطفين
و
نحن نقول ان القوات الاسرائيليه لم تتجاوز
قواعد
الحرب وسيكون هنالك تحقيقا تق يقوم به
النظام القضائي الاسرائيلي ولكن لم تكن
النيه تدمير بشكل كلي او جزئي جماعه من
الناس ان افعال اسرائيل وفي تحديد اهدافها
لاستهداف مقاتلين او اهداف عسكريه وفقا
للقانون الانساني الدولي
وبشكل متناسب وفي كل حاله من تلك الحالات
وحتى ممارسات المتعلقه بالحد من الحاق ضرر
بالمدنيين بما في ذلك انذار المدنيين بشان
عمليات عسكريه وهذا امر غير مسبوق واستخ
ومن خلال استخدام الاتصالات الهاتفيه
والمنشورات
و مع
تسهيل مساعدات انسانيه وتوفير مساعدات كل
ذلك يثبت نقيض اي مزاع
بوجود نيه للاباده الجماعيه جنوب افريقيا
ومن خلال
سعيها ل
لاثبات ركن النيه عرضت صوره مشوهه
[موسيقى]
ومغلوطة
او تملك نظام وهيكل سلطه تتعلق باتخاذ
القرارات الحكوميه ان الحرب ضد
حماس تم شنها بالنيابه عن الحكومه من
قبل اذا قرارات اعمال الحرب تقوم بها
هيئتان
وحكومه
الحرب التي تم انشاؤها من اجل اداره اعمال
الحرب من قبل الحكومه
السياسيه ان هاتين الهيئتين تتخذان
القرارات المتعلقه بممارسات الحرب
والعمليات العسكريه وفقا للقوانين
الاسرائيليه وقرارات الحكومه
ولجانها وتلزم الوزراء
وفقا المسؤوليه الجماعيه
لحكومه وبالتالي هذا قرار جماعي او قرارات
جماعيه تتخذها تلك
الكيانات رئيس الوزراء هو راس هذه
الكيانات ويقرر اجنده الاجتماعات ويشرف
على اجراءاتها ويقوم
بتلخيص القرارات وللتوضيح
من اجل تحديد سياسات ونوايا حكومه
اسرائيل من الضروري بمكان تمحيص القرارات
التي تصدر
عن الحكومه الاساسيه وحكومه الحرب والتحقق
من ان اي تصريحات صدرت تتفق او تتساوق او
لا تتساوق مع
القرارات التي صدرت اخذ
تصريح
عشوائي
ووصفه وهذا لا يمكن وصفه الا انه
مظلل ان التصريحات التي تصدر مثلا عن
وزاره التراث وهي خارج اليه او عمليه
اتخاذ
القرارات مثل تلك التصريحات يتم دحضها و
بشكل سريع من قبل اعضاء في حكومه الحرب
وغيرهم من الاعضاء بما في ذلك رئيس
الوزراء
في المجلد الاول الذي قدمته اسرائيل ل
المحكمه
ستجدون
مقتطفات من تصريحات
لمسؤولين اسرائيليين يعبرون فيهم عن
نواياهم
الحقيقيه ومثلا ما ورد من توجيهات من رئيس
الوزراء
للجنه شؤون الامن القومي في التاسع من ع
اكتوبر والتي تنص على التالي او تقول
التالي رئيس الوزراء اكد مرار وتكرارا بان
عل ان نحول دون حدوث كارثه انسانيه ثانيا
رئيس الوزراء اشار بشان مجموعه من الحلول
التي يمكن ان تضمن وصول المياه والغذاء
والادويه للفلسطينيين وزياده عدد الشاحنات
عند خضوعها للتفتيش اللازم
ثالثا انشاء مستشفى ميداني في جنوب قطاع
غزه وهذا يؤكد على
ان هذا استخدام لاص سلطات الا اكثر ولا
اقل المجلد الثاني يتضمن عددا كبيرا من
التوجيهات الحكوميه وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
ب عدم الحق الاذى والضرر بالمدنيين وتسهيل
وصول المساعدات هل هذا يعبر عن وجود نيه
[موسيقى]
للاباده
هذا كل الجيوش تعمل وفقا لترات بيه محدده
بموجب
اوامر عن هيئه الاركان او رئيس هيئه
الاركان اي تصريحات او
افعال
لجنود لا يمكن ان تعكس تعكس او لا تعكس او
لا يمكن ان تعكس السياسات الحكوميه وفي
المجلد
ب سنجد بعض
التوجيهات اليوميه المتكرره
والصادره عن اداره العمليات العسكريه في
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي وتشير بان الهجمات
يجب ان تست تهدف فقط الاهداف العسكريه مع
الالتزام بمبادئ التمييز والتناسب واتخاذ
التحوطات اللازمه اثناء تلك الهجمات وذلك
من اجل التخفيف من الاضرار الجانبيه واذا
هذا
توجيه يصدر لكل قوات
الجيش ان قانون النزاعات
المسلحه
يسمح بحدوث اضرار
لمنشات ومرافق مدنيه عندما يكون هناك
ضروره عسكريه ولكن يحضر على القوات
العسكريه معاقبه افراد او جماعات وهو يؤكد
على انه من الضروري التعامل مع موضوع
المدنيين او الجانب باحترام دون غش او او
معاملتهم بشكل مذل او مهين وينبغي ان
يستخدم
المدنيون لغايات تنفيذ انشطه يمكن ان تعرض
حياتهم او اجسامهم للخطر اذا هذه توجيهات
اساسيه رئيسيه تم اصدارها منذ بدايه الحرب
والمجلد يتضمن الكثير من الاحكام والتي
تبرهن
وتظهر وجود مثل تلك التوجيهات او
الاجراءات الواجب اتباعها في ال8 من
اكتوبر رئيس الوزراء وبشكل عليني اوضح بان
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي يقوم بكل كل ما في
وسعه من اجل عدم الحاق اي اذن او ضرر بغير
المشاركين في هذا الحرب وفي 18ا عش من
اكتوبر اعلن قال انه فوق كل شيء اسرائيل
ينبغي ان تتصرف وفقا لقانون الح الحرب اذا
هكذا يعمل
جيشنا وزير الدفاع ذكر وبتصريح العلاني في
التاسع ع من اكتوبر قال اننا لا
نحارب الشعب الفلسطيني والفلسطيني في غزه
واعلن في الث عش من نوفمبر قال ان حربنا
هي ضد ضد المنظمه الارهابيه منظمه الحماس
الارهابيه وليس ضد الشعب الفلسطيني ومره
اخرى رئيس الوزراء اعلن في الثاني عش من
اكتوبر باننا نعمل وان ننفذ عملياتنا
العسكريه وفقا لقوانين الحرب وقانون
الانسان الدولي بشكل قاطع وقمنا بجمع عديد
التصريحات الصادره عن عن الرئيس ورئيس
الوزراء ووزير الدفاع باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي وغيرهم كل ذلك في المجلد
الثاني وحيث ان هذا جزء مهم في دعوه جنوب
افريقيا اود ان اشير الى تصريحين اخرين
صدرا عن رئيس الوزراء ابدا اخره وهو في
العاشر ما صدر عنه في العاشر من يناير قال
ان ليس لدى اسرائيل اي نيه لاحتلال غزه او
تهجير سكانها المواطنين اسرائيل تقاتل
ارهابي حماس وليس الشعب الفلسطيني ونحن
نفعل ذلك ونقوم بذلك بالالتزام الكامل مع
القوانين الدوليه جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يقوم بكل ما في وسع من اجل الحد من
الضحايا في صفوف المدنيين في الوقت الذي
تقوم فيه حماس بزياده عدد الضحايا في صف
المدنيين من خلال استخدام كدروع بشريه
والجيش
الاسرائيلي يسمح للمواطنين
الفلسطينين مغادره مناطق النزاع من خلال
عن
طريق صالات والمنش والمناشير وغيرها وكذلك
توفير ممرات انسانيه في الوقت
الذي تمنع حماس المواطنين من المغادره
باستخدام
السلاح الهدف هو انشاء او ايجاد مستقبل
افضل بالنسبه الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
على حد سواء من